Yves, warum stehst du eigentlich
jeden Morgen auf?
- Meistens, weil ich pinkeln muss.
- Sehr romantisch.
Manchmal auch, weil ich Hunger habe.
Aber in der Regel kommt
meine kleine Tochter und schreit.
Du bist begeistert von der Frage.
Das ist der Klassiker
der Philosophie.
Eine schöne Frage,
die man verschieden verstehen kann.
Es gibt ja das grosse Sinnproblem,
wenn man von aussen ...
- Vogelperspektive.
... aus dem Weltall
auf uns hinabschaut.
Man fragt sich: Was ist der Sinn?
Irgendwann sterben wir Menschen aus,
die Erde implodiert in die Sonne.
Dann gab es uns mal,
aber alles ist vorbei.
Und auf diese Frage
habe ich keine Antwort.
Ich würde sagen:
So ist wahrscheinlich das Leben.
Das ist einfach sinnlos.
Das ist wohl der Unterschied zwischen
Gläubigen und Nicht-Gläubigen.
Viele Gläubige widersprächen wohl
und sagten, wir seien gottgewollt
oder es gebe
den grossen Plan dahinter.
Aber die Philosophie ist nicht fertig
bei der Vogelperspektive,
sondern würde sagen,
es gebe die Froschperspektive.
Du liegst im Bett
und stellst dir die Sinnfrage.
Noch etwas
zur religiösen Perspektive:
Für mich war das auch nie wirklich
eine Antwort auf das Sinnproblem.
Angenommen, es gibt einen Gott und
ein Leben nach dem Tod, einen Plan -
man fragt sich doch trotzdem:
Warum gibt es all das?
Warum gibt es nicht einfach nichts?
Warum gibt es Gott und warum
hat er uns erst dann geschaffen?
Man lädt sich unglaublich viele
Probleme zusätzlich auf,
die die Sinnfrage für mich
auch nicht beantworten.
Der britische Philosoph
Terry Eagleton sagte mal so schön,
der Sinn des Lebens liege nicht
wie der Blinddarm im Unterbauch,
sondern man müsse ihn finden,
man müsse ihn konstruieren.
- Das wäre eben
diese Froschperspektive. - Genau.
Man sagt: So, wie wir als Wesen
unsere Leben führen,
können wir das sinnvoller
oder weniger sinnvoll tun.
Es ist eigentlich
eine stetige Aufgabe für uns,
den Sinn des Lebens zu konstruieren.
Dort gibt es vieles,
zu dem ich Intuitionen habe.
Z.B., wenn ich mich entfalten kann,
also Freiheit, Autonomie,
mein eigenes Leben leben
und kein irgendwie vorgegebenes
oder gezwungen sein,
irgendetwas zu tun.
Dann fühlt sich das Freie
irgendwie sinnvoller an.
Und das andere,
das genauso wichtig ist:
helfen, irgendetwas Gutes tun.
Jemand anderem zu helfen ist
für mich so etwas von sinnstiftend.
Das hinterfragt man viel weniger.
Jemand,
der bei Ärzte ohne Grenzen arbeitet
und seine Lebensenergie darin
investiert, in arme Länder zu gehen
und Krankheiten zu bekämpfen,
weiss, wofür er aufsteht.
Mir leuchtet extrem ein,
was du sagst.
Ich glaube trotzdem, man kann
die Frage nach dem Sinn des Lebens
auch in bestimmter Art und Weise
zu ernst oder zu wenig ernst nehmen.
Ich glaube, die, die sie
zu wenig ernst nehmen, sind Zyniker.
Die, die sie zu ernst nehmen,
könnten aber die sein ...
Du hast Médecins sans frontières
erwähnt.
Wer hat etwas
gegen eine solche Tätigkeit?
Natürlich ist das in hohem Grad
nicht nur sinnstiftend,
sondern auch sinnvoll.
Aber jemand, der sagt,
sein Leben mache Sinn,
weil er so unglaublich wichtig sei,
würde es zu ernst nehmen.
Dann kippt es in den Narzissmus.
Narzissmus und Zynismus sind
keine guten Antworten oder Haltungen.
Es gibt ja
ganz verschiedene Lebensentwürfe.
Es gibt Menschen,
die Dinge wichtig finden,
die für mich total unwichtig sind.
Z.B. irgendwo shoppen gehen
oder ein Wochenende lang gamen.
Das ist mir einfach nicht wichtig.
Für sie ist das aber wichtig.
Und im Regelfall würde ich sie
auch nicht kritisieren.
Trotzdem gibt es Beispiele,
bei denen man sagen möchte:
"Leb doch anders,
du führst kein sinnvolles Leben."
Einer, der nur auf dem Sofa sitzt,
Chips frisst und fernsieht,
seine Talente verschwendet,
nichts daraus macht
und niemandem hilft.
Ein sehr schönes Beispiel finde ich
in der Theorie der Gerechtigkeit
von John Rawls den Grashalmzähler.
Das ist ein Mathematiker,
der eine grossartige mathematische
Karriere an der Uni macht.
Aber seine liebste Tätigkeit
ist bäuchlings im Gras liegen
und Grashalme zählen.
Man möchte sagen: Entschuldigung,
es gäbe Sinnvolleres zu tun.
Welcher Blick auf diese Person
erlaubt uns eigentlich,
ein solches Urteil zu fällen?
Wenn das für ihn erfüllend ist
und er es als wichtig empfindet -
wer bin ich dann,
ihm etwas vorzuschreiben
oder ihm zu sagen,
er habe sein Leben verfehlt?
Ich finde es extrem heikel.
Ich würde das
in sehr wenigen Fällen tun.
Ist für dich nur die subjektive
Bewertung ausschlaggebend?
- Gibt es keine objektiven Kriterien?
- Nenn sie mir.
Was ein sinnvolles Leben
für jeden Menschen ist?
Pff, was weiss ich?
Du hast z.B.
so etwas wie Entfaltung genannt.
Das finde ich
ein sehr gutes Stichwort.
Diese Idee
hatte auch Aristoteles sehr stark.
Wie eine Blume, die sich entfalten
und ihren Kelch ausbreiten kann,
können auch wir Menschen
etwas aus uns machen, etwas werden.
- Aus dem Potenzial.
- Genau, unser Potenzial ausschöpfen.
Das finde ich schon erstrebenswert.
Aber warum ist das erstrebenswert?
Und sind wir nicht irgendwie auch
Kinder der eigenen Zeit?
Stichwort Selbstoptimierung,
Selbstentfaltung, Individualismus.
Wenn einer
ein unglaubliches Talent ist
im Piano-, Geigen-
oder Tennisspielen,
es aber einfach nicht so gern tut,
muss er es nicht tun.
Oder würdest du sagen:
"Du hast ein Riesentalent,
du könntest
der neue Roger Federer werden"?
"Mach etwas aus dir!"
Und er sagt: "Keinen Bock."
Du hast völlig recht,
aber der Perfektionierungsgedanke,
eine Eigenschaft perfektionieren
zu müssen, Roger Federer zu werden,
ist in dieser Idee des
Sich-Entfaltens noch nicht enthalten.
Jemand, der sich entfaltet, hat
typischerweise verschiedene Seiten.
Ich glaube, die meisten würden sagen,
zu einem sinnvollen Leben gehört es,
soziale Beziehungen zu haben,
zu lieben.
Aber was, wenn es jemandem gut geht,
der das nicht hat?
Z.B. jemand,
der autistisch veranlagt ist,
die Tendenz hat oder einfach eine
etwas asoziale Persönlichkeit ist,
der keine Lust auf das hat.
Man kann nicht sagen,
der Mensch sei so
und wer nicht so lebe, lebe
am Leben vorbei oder nicht sinnvoll.
- Finde ich auch heikel.
- Okay.
Ich habe bisher zwei Dinge genannt:
Freiheit, also Selbstentfaltung,
helfen - Altruismus.
Dazu kommt noch: lernen zu sterben.
Ich glaube, das ist etwas,
was das Leben ausmacht.
Dazu müssen wir ein Verhältnis,
eine Haltung finden.
Ich glaube trotzdem, wenn man morgens
immer und immer wieder aufsteht,
macht man sich selten
die grossen Gedanken.
Die macht man sich wohl auch,
manchmal überfallen sie einen
auch hinterrücks.
Aber vieles von der Routine,
die wir im Leben haben,
und vom Gefühl, es sei manchmal etwas
repetitiv, langweilig und sinnlos,
ist eher das Gefühl,
das Camus beschreibt:
Sisyphos, der den Fels hinaufrollt,
der rollt wieder hinunter,
er rollt ihn hinauf,
er rollt hinunter.
Man kann es nicht wirklich ändern.
Alles, was einem helfen würde,
auszusteigen, wäre Selbstmord -
keine wirkliche Option,
das wollen wir nicht propagieren.
Das findet übrigens auch Camus
eine feige Haltung.
Was bleibt,
ist etwas wie eine ironische Distanz.
Das sagt z.B. Thomas Nagel,
der amerikanische Philosoph,
der sagte, ironische Distanz
sei die richtige Lebenshaltung
oder gehöre sehr eng
zum Sinn des Lebens.
Sich einerseits
die Frage stellen zu können,
gleichzeitig aber
über sich selbst lachen zu können
in der Sehnsucht danach,
eine Frage beantwortet zu bekommen,
die wir nicht beantworten können.
- Schön.
- Schön: Ironie als Lebenshaltung.
Bei Camus gibt es
einen weiteren Aspekt. Er sagt:
"Wir müssen uns Sisyphos als
glücklichen Menschen vorstellen."
Weil er in einen Flow kommt,
sich selbst vergisst,
die ganze Frage vergisst,
die Perspektive von Sinn oder Unsinn
vergisst.
Er taucht ab
in die Sinnlichkeit des Felsens,
der Schweiss rinnt hinunter,
er stemmt sich dagegen,
hat ein Projekt,
macht es zu seinem eigenen,
entfaltet sich so, gibt sich
eine Aufgabe, die er erfüllt.
Das ist für mich auch eine Form,
Sinn zu finden.
Was ich noch vergessen habe,
ist Liebe.
- Das hatten wir noch nicht.
- Aber Beziehungen.
Genau, das ist für mich
d i e grosse Sinnstiftung.
Liebe ist auch
eine Erweiterung des Ichs.
Ich könnte stundenlang
über diese Frage reden.
Es ist eine grundlegende Frage
der Philosophiegeschichte.
Dennoch muss ich am Ende immer lachen
wegen Reinhold Niebuhr.
Der Theologe und Philosoph sagte:
"Immer wenn ich den Sinn des Lebens
gefunden habe, ändern sie ihn."
- Wer sie?
- Ja, gut.
- Irgendjemand?
- Ich finde es eine lustige Position.
Man denkt, man habe etwas,
und dann war es wieder nichts.
Es ist eben flüchtig.
Dass ein gelingendes Leben viel damit
zu tun hat, selbstbestimmt zu leben,
sagt z.B.
die Philosophin Beate Rössler.
Mit ihr haben wir gesprochen.
Und mit Remo Largo über die Frage:
Welches ist das Leben,
das zu mir passt?
Schaut unsere Gespräche nach: hier.